it was august 1961
and president john f kennedy was
addressing his director of central
intelligence alan dulles
president said
under a parliamentary system of
government it is i who would be leaving
office but under our system it is you
who must go
kennedy was furious with the cia over
the botched invasion of cuba at the bay
of pigs five months earlier
at the time he'd said that he'd like to
splinter the cia into a thousand pieces
but out of respect for the 68 year old
dollars he'd let the old spymaster hang
on so that he could preside over the
completion of his pet project the
november 1961 dedication of the cia's
new headquarters in leafy langley
virginia
still the circumstances of dulles
departure from the agency were deeply
humiliating
he spent the remaining years of his life
until his death in 1969 watching
unhappily as the nation became almost
unrecognizable to him
next ago was the cia's deputy director
of plans richard bissell the man most
responsible for the bay of pigs fiasco
bissell was offered the agency's new
directorate of science and technology
but he turned down the offer it felt
like a demotion after having
masterminded covert ops worldwide
instead bissell moved into private
consultancy work
his post was taken up by a long time
rival the relatively cautious
intelligence professional richard helms
the departure of dullers and bissell
signaled a course change at the cia
ever since its founding in 1947 the
agency had been pulled between the two
missions of analysis and covert
operations
under dollars the cia had leaned heavily
toward operations
now there would be a swing of the
pendulum back to traditional
intelligence work
in the words of the washington columnist
stuart alsop the prudent professionals
were taking over from the bold
easterners
the clearest sign of this was kennedy's
choice to replace dulles as director of
central intelligence john a mccone
whereas dulles was all old yankee
aristocracy and romanticized spy games
mccone was a self-made corporate manager
with as a former classmate put it a
slide rule mind
born on the west coast some 59 years
earlier he had trained as an engineer
and made a fortune building ships in los
angeles before crossing into a series of
senior government positions
soon after moving to langley mccomb made
it clear that providing intelligence was
going to take precedence over the cloak
and dagger stuff of his predecessor
and unlike alan duller's mccomb made a
point of carefully reading the national
intelligence estimates that went to the
white house
going over them meticulously with a pen
so in a sense
the bay of pigs debacler put the cia in
a better state to respond to a second
crisis in cuba that took place the
following year
that's when the soviet union tried
secretly to place nuclear weapons on the
island and was caught in the app by the
united states
it's difficult to exaggerate the
importance of this event the cuban
missile crisis of october 1962 was
arguably the defining episode of the
cold war and the moment when the world
came closest to a nuclear confrontation
and while a vast amount has been written
about the subject i'm going to summarize
some of the more recent scholarship with
a particular eye on the cia's
performance during the cuban missile
crisis i'll begin by talking about the
agency's contribution to the causes of
the crisis and then assess how the
agency performed during the 13 days
between the detection of the missiles
and the agreement between the two
superpowers leading to their removal
overall i'll argue that the cia's
performance was mixed but basically good
however this didn't entirely make up for
the damage done to its reputation by the
bay of pigs episode indeed when the
kennedy era ended the following year the
cia would be in a worse position than it
had been at the beginning
so why did soviet premier nikita
khrushchev try to put missiles on cuba
in the first place
historians have suggested various
reasons for khrushchev's move which for
him was uncharacteristically risky
the united states had just taken a clear
lead in the nuclear arms race so perhaps
khrushchev saw the soviet's cuban
missile operation which they called
anadir
as a way to catch up
he might also have been trying to force
america's hand in berlin which remained
at cold war flashpoint a year after the
berlin wall started going up it's even
possible he was using cuba to impress
the chinese an emerging rival in the
communist block
it's unclear which of these motives
might have been uppermost in
khrushchev's mind or even if he had
other considerations
but there is general agreement that he
wouldn't have gone through with his
gamble of placing nukes in america's
backyard
had it not been for us hostility to
fidel castro khrushchev faced a lot of
importance on being seen as willing and
able to defend his communist allies in
the third world
furthermore castro wouldn't have agreed
to accept the missiles if he hadn't felt
under continuing threat from the united
states
despite the failed 1961 invasion of cuba
president kennedy was still determined
to get rid of castro
the u.s feared that communist cuba might
knock over other dominoes in latin
america
castro posed a threat to u.s credibility
and engendered the personal hatred of
some american officials
added to this was the brooding sense of
humiliation kennedy felt after the bay
of pigs
so in the months leading up to the
missile crisis washington sent one
unsubtle signal after another that it
was still after castro
these culminated in early october 1962
with a simulated assault by the marines
on a small island near puerto rico
the u.s publicized details of the
exercise including the name of its
made-up target ortsack
castro spelt backwards
as the kennedy administration engaged in
these overt measures the cia was
resuming the sort of covert operations
that had preceded the bay of pig's
invasion
the impetus came from the white house
and in particular from the president's
younger brother bobby kennedy
the u.s attorney general effectively
took personal control of the covert
campaign against castro after the bay of
pigs
following the replacement of dulles and
bissell by mccone and helms the cia
itself was in a much less bullish mood
regarding cuba
in november 1961 the cia and pentagon
jointly launched operation mongoose a 50
million dollar a year program that bobby
kennedy hoped would stir things up on in
the island with espionage sabotage and
general disorder by the following year a
cia base in oprah locker florida code
named jm wave was the agency's largest
outside langley
it employed 400 clandestine service
officers as well as thousands of cuban
exiles
it also ran as many as 400 front
companies throughout south florida and
managed the third largest navy in the
caribbean
maintaining secrecy
in such a huge operation was nearly
impossible as it had been before the bay
of pigs
the base was teeming with gun merchants
soldiers of fortune and cuban politicos
hoping to replace castro
its presence was an open secret in
florida
richard helms wanted mongoose to
generate intelligence as well as covert
action
so he set up a reception center at the
florida base to debrief thousands of
cubans still fleeing castro
thanks to mongoose the cia had a better
espionage network on the island than
before the bay of pigs
but as in earlier operations there was
also a lot of silliness such as
proposals for air drops of toilet paper
with portraits of castro and khrushchev
printed on alternate squares
and there were more assassination plots
many more
responding to castro's known fondness
for ocean diving one proposal involved
coating the cuban's diving suit with
deadly contaminants
another for planting a beautiful
seashell rigged with explosives near his
favorite diving beach
helms brought in a familiar face to
oversee the planning this was william
harvey the heavy drinking pistol-packing
ex-fbi man who would run the cia's
berlin station
in his new role harvey was introduced to
johnny rosselli uh the mobster had been
recruited to help the agency with
earlier attempts to eliminate castro
harvey and roselli got along famously
helms by the way didn't inform mccone
about the efforts to kill castro knowing
the director would object due to his
strong catholic faith
helms himself maintained reservations
believing that efforts to assassinate
foreign leaders invited the risk of
retaliation in kind
and none of it worked the only real
effect of operation mongoose was to make
castro even more suspicious of the
americans and to drive him further into
the arms of the soviets
defense secretary robert mcnamara said
later if i was a cuban and read the
evidence of covert american action
against their government
i would be quite ready to believe that
the us intended to mount an invasion
and it's worth adding that even though
jack and bobby kennedy's dislike of
castro was unique in its intensity the
cuban operations weren't an isolated cia
phenomenon
in relative terms the kennedy era saw
more covert ops than the eisenhower
years had especially in the western
hemisphere
during the early 60s the u.s engaged in
covert actions in the dominican republic
ecuador british guyana and brazil
and in efforts to support repressive
anti-communist governments in other
countries castro in looking around
might be forgiven for thinking that jack
kennedy was laying siege to latin
america
so in the summer of 1962 castro decided
to go along with khrushchev on deploying
nuclear missiles on cuba hoping that
doing so might deter the americans from
further aggression
to summarize
although the cia was not the driving
force
that would have been the kennedy
brothers
its anti-castro operations did
contribute to the siege mentality that
opened cuba up to soviet missiles
so
how was the agency's performance during
the rest of the cuban missile crisis
starting with the american discovery of
the missiles
well at the beginning not very good
agency analysts noted an increase of
soviet shipments to cuba in july 1962
and a u2 overflight photographed a new
surface-to-air missile site that august
but at this stage the cia along with the
rest of the us intelligence community
believed that soviet weapons on the
island were limited to the conventional
defensive kind
on september 19 1962 the agency stated
in a now notorious national intelligence
estimate that nothing in khrushchev's
previous behavior suggested he would do
something as reckless as deploying
offensive nukes so close to the united
states
meanwhile president kennedy ordered a
suspension of u-2 reconnaissance flights
over cuba fearing another incident like
the soviet shoot down of u.s pilot gary
powers in may 1960.
the cia was now in something akin to an
intelligence shutdown in cuba
however
one dissenting voice in washington
belonged to none other than the cia
director john mccone
that august and september he repeatedly
voiced a hunch that the soviets were
putting offensive weapons on cuba while
on his honeymoon in the south of france
mccone even sent the white house cables
to that effect
other national security experts were
skeptical attributing his suspicion of
khrushchev to his catholicism his
anti-communism and a lack of previous
government intelligence experience
still
reports were coming in from mongoose
field agents about mysterious movements
of unusually long soviet traders near
the northwestern cuban town of san
cristobal
on october 9th kennedy relented and
authorized a resumption of u2 flights
over cuba
now the cia's performance went from
below par to stella
the first reconnaissance mission flew at
dawn on october 14th
piloted by air force major richard d
heiser
the following day analysts in the cia's
national photographic interpretation
center examined the images heiser had
taken
they showed three missile sites around
san cristobal
subsequent youtube flights would reveal
three more sites near san cristobal and
two at guanaj
the american analysts compared these
missiles with photographs of mayday
parades in moscow and consulted
technical manuals provided to them by a
spy and soviet military intelligence
named oleg penkovsky
by the late afternoon of october 15th
they'd reached an alarming conclusion
the initial battery consisted of ss4
medium-range ballistic missiles capable
of carrying nuclear warheads 300 miles
as far as washington
richard helms took the news to bobby
kennedy early the next morning his reply
damn it all to hell and back
to sum up the cia's performance in the
run-up to the crisis agency officials
with the notable exception of john
mccone failed to predict the soviet
deployment on cuba
but then they made up for their initial
error by skillfully using technological
and human intelligence to detect the
missiles
some historians have even forgiven the
cia analyst their earlier era given that
khrushchev's actions were so out of
character
in any case thanks to the cia and in
particular the much maligned richard
bissell john kennedy now had some
valuable intelligence and time in which
to craft a response before moscow was
aware that its scheme had been
discovered
on october 16 1962
kennedy assembled the executive
committee of the national security
council this was the group known as xcom
consisting of the so-called wise men of
foreign policy who would advise the
president on how to respond
kennedy's first instinct was to order up
airstrikes on the missile sites
in the course of x-com discussions
however the president backed away from
the military option fearing that it
might start a full-scale nuclear war
in a national tv address on october 22nd
kennedy demanded that the soviets
withdraw the missiles
and he announced that he was imposing a
naval quarantine on cuba to prevent any
more soviet shipments from reaching it
the world held its breath as soviet
ships sailed toward the quarantine line
but on october 24th they began turning
back
when xcom learned this secretary of
state dean rusk lent over the national
security adviser george bundy and said
we are eyeball to eyeball and i think
the other fellow just blinked
kennedy's strategy was working
but the crisis wasn't over yet missiles
remained on cuba
now the cia's performance during the
crisis wasn't perfect
agency analysts substantially
underestimated the number of soviet
troops on cuba
reckoning a total of eight thousand to
ten thousand when the true figure was
nearer to forty three 000.
they also missed evidence of tactical
nuclear weapons on the island including
some missiles aimed at the u.s naval
base in guantanamo bay
had jfk decided on air strikes followed
by an invasion american forces would
have met with much more resistance than
the cia had predicted and the presence
of tactical nukes spelled the
possibility of a rapid escalation to
all-out nuclear war
overall though the cia performed well
mccone's daily briefings to xcom on the
latest intelligence developments were
effective
and he was able to be supported by the
head of the national photographic
interpretation center a man named art
lundell
further agency analysts atone for the
erroneous national intelligence estimate
of september 19th by providing two
updated estimates on october 20th about
possible u.s actions and likely soviet
responses
these structured much of xcom's
subsequent debate
one particularly gratifying moment came
after president kennedy's october 22nd
tv address
when the soviet representative to the
united nations security council valerian
zorin demanded evidence of the missile's
existence in response u.s representative
adlai stevenson produced a series of u-2
and lower-level reconnaissance
photographs making the soviets squirm in
his seat
here was the cia doing what it was
founded to do providing u.s leaders with
central intelligence
still i don't want to create the
impression that the kennedy
administration was entirely in control
of events
recent historical scholarship argues
that the cuban missile crisis was more
dangerous than the world knew at the
time
even as american and soviet leaders
worked over the weekend of october 27th
and 28th toward a resolution that would
bring the 13-day crisis to an end
a new series of incidents could have
tipped the super powers into full-scale
conflict
first on the night of october 26th to
27th a u-2 plane based in alaska strayed
into soviet airspace
the pilot captain chuck monsby was on a
routine mission collecting air samples
to monitor soviet nuclear tests
but he became confused by the aurora
borealis the northern lights
while navigating by the stars and he
drifted off course
soviet mig scrambled to intercept the u2
and u.s fighters took off to rescue it
u.s forces were in a state of defcon 2
nuclear alert and american planes were
carrying air-to-air missiles with
low-yield nuclear warheads and no
electronic locks disaster loomed it was
possible that the soviets might
interpret this as a reconnaissance
mission preparing for a u.s first strike
as american nuclear war planning
dictated
fortunately u.s authorities guided
maltsby back to base before the opposing
fighter planes engaged
then
on october 27th black saturday as it
became known another u2 was shot down by
a soviet surface-to-air missile while
overflying cuba
the pilot major rudolf anderson have
returned from previous u2 missions with
some of the earliest photographs of the
cuban missile sites
now it would be photographs of his three
children that the cubans recovered next
to his dead body
the white house considered bombing the
surface-to-air missile battery that
launched the attack
but the decision had been that of a
local soviet commander acting on his own
initiative and not a kremlin order
still as the tension of black saturday
mounted there was a growing sense that
events were spinning out of control
the most dangerous incident took place
not in the sky but in the ocean
the u.s navy was pursuing four
submarines of the soviet northern fleet
of cuba dropping hand grenades and depth
charges to get them to surface
what the navy didn't know was that in
addition to conventional armaments each
submarine was carrying a nuclear torpedo
with a yield equal to the bomb dropped
on hiroshima
several of the soviet submarine captains
interpreted the detonations as attacks
rather than warnings
one submariner compared the blast to
sledgehammers pounding on a metal barrel
conditions were particularly desperate
aboard submarine b-59
where rising temperatures and carbon
dioxide levels caused men to faint
captain valentin savitsky ordered his
crew to arm the nuclear torpedo he said
we're gonna blast them now we will die
but we will sink them all
other officers managed to calm him and
persuaded him to surface
of all the incidents on black saturday
perhaps this one came closest to
starting world war iii
october 27th the most dangerous day of
the cuban missile crisis was also
crucial to its resolution khrushchev
sent kennedy an impassioned letter
voicing his fear of nuclear war and
offering to withdraw the missiles in
return for a pledge that the united
states would not invade cuba
but only hours later the soviet premier
followed up with a second letter
demanding that the united states remove
some of its nuclear armory near the
soviet union
these were the jupiter missiles in
turkey
khrushchev's offer was the subject of
heated debate at xcom where members were
exhausted after nearly two weeks of high
stress
john mccone who'd generally taken a hard
line in dealing with the soviets now
advised accepting the offer pointing out
that the jupiter missiles were
technologically obsolescent anyway
that evening bobby kennedy met secretly
with the soviet ambassador
anatoly dobrinin and agreed to the terms
in return for the soviets dismantling
their missiles on the island the united
states would promise publicly to not
invade cuba and secretly remove its own
jupiter missiles
by the way this was all done without
consulting fidel castro who was furious
with the soviets as well as with the
americans
the following morning radio moscow
announced that the cuban missiles were
being returned to the soviet union
jfk told an aide
i feel like a new man now thank god it's
all over
the cia had done well during the crisis
and would continue to perform
effectively afterwards in monitoring and
verifying the soviet removal of the
missiles
but it got surprisingly little thanks
for its contributions the kennedys had
still not forgotten the bay of pigs
fiasco nor the subsequent failures of
operation mongoose which arguably helped
cause the crisis in the first place
and john mccombe perhaps spent too much
time reminding people that he was the
only us official to have predicted
trouble
this was true but it was also
embarrassing to the president who in
march 1963 could be heard saying he's a
real bastard that john mccomb
and even now the kennedys couldn't give
up their castro obsession
in june 1963 the national security
council approved a new program of
sabotage after the cuban leader returned
from a trip to moscow
the assassination plotting resumed as
well this time under the charge of the
far east hand desmond fitzgerald who was
a throwback to the dulles era of
gentleman adventurers
the planning now focused on a
disaffected cuban government official
named rolando kubala
on november 22nd cia officers met with q
baylor in paris and provided him with a
ballpoint pen
rigged with a poisonous hypodermic
needle to use on fidel castro
this was also the day of john kennedy's
assassination in dallas
conspiracy theories that there was a
direct connection between the repeated
cia attempts to kill castro and
president kennedy's death
have never been proven
but the suspicions would haunt the
agency for years to come
and further tarnish its reputation in
washington
[Music]
you